Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Here's a really instructive question
from a viewer Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: Yeah, David, you describe
yourself as a left winger, right? But
seems like you're a pretty big supporter
of capitalism. How do you reconcile that?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Well, listen, this this goes to
some significant confusion. Most left wingers are
not socialists. This is just it's an empirical
reality. Most, many left wingers like me support
socialization of some elements of society
and the economy. I want to take health care
outside of the capitalist system. I want to take
education outside of that. There are arguments for
with some aspects of housing, but not all taking
it outside of just supply and demand and markets.
But most left wingers are not actually socialists.
Even in countries like my birth country of
Argentina with big socialist traditions, most
of the left wingers are not actually socialists,
so there's no conflict. I'm a social Democrat
in the style. Of some blend of northern European
countries, I support a much, much more regulated
and controlled version of capitalism whose main
priority is let's use the fruits of that regulated
capitalism to set a much higher floor for
everybody, for the betterment of all. Let's also
set some kind of ceiling above which we really are
collecting a lot of taxes for the betterment
of society. It's called social democracy,
but I don't need a I'm fine with markets dictating
resource allocation for consumer electronics,
vehicles, products of different kinds. I'm
okay with that. I think it's OK. I think
if you build something and it's a company and it's
yours and you built it, I don't think that should
be taken away from you. However, we recognize
that you built it based on utility infrastructure
established by the government and through track
taxation protection and for intellectual property
established by the government, presumably with
employees, many of whom went to public schools,
which is paid for but through tax, right?
When we recognize, well, yet you, you
organized the structure and you built it, and so
you do deserve many of the fruits of that labor.
It was also built on the backs of all sorts
of government infrastructure and tax dollars,
et cetera, et cetera. So that's why we have to
cycle back a portion of it into the betterment of
society. That's fundamentally social democracy.
It is a left wing perspective. I would argue
it's the most successful, most successful version
of progressive ideology globally over the last
hundred and fifty years. OK, so that's my
perspective. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. Absolutely insane travel chaos. And it's
not just an causing it. We will talk about Hillary
Clinton's interesting 2024 prediction. We'll talk
about how on earth new schools reopen with Macron
spreading so wildly and much more. All of
those stories on today's bonus show. Sign
up at Join Packman dot com and you can use the
coupon code. Wow. 22. And when you type it in,
you have to. You have to say, Wow. 22. It saves
you big. You get access to the bonus show. You
joined the ranks of membership for what will be a
really important election year. I'll see you then.